Anh có sẽ chính thức tổ chức mâu cửa tổng thống và ngay mũ ba thằng sấu,
sau nhiều tháng bất ổ chí chi bị lạnh thết của luật của cửa tổng thống dung sức gần.
Thào thống Ké, hơn 1 mũ mấy bốn chiệu cửa chi sẽ quyết định đời đất nước trong buổi cảnh kinh tế chứng lạc.
Anh ninh khu cửa căng thằng và sảo hội đối mắt nhiều thách thức.
Cú thể của mâu cửa viện ra từ sau giờ đến 20 giờ ngay mũ ba thằng sấu,
hay ứng viên đào dẫn đầu của cửa theo các kết quảng in kỳu,
là ông Li Jemong của đả dân chủ đối lập với bối mũ chiến thân chăm tì lệ ông Hó,
và ông Kim Moon Suu của đảng quyền lực nhân dân gần quyền có 3 mũ thân chăm tì lệ ông Hó.
Trong buổi bản động trang cửa của công,
2 viên liên tục chuy trích nhau về các gần đề phó lọt và chính sách trọng nộ lực thú hút cửa chi đến về phía mình.
Dù ông Li hè ông Moon đã cửa tân tổng thống hàn quốc sẽ phải đở mặt với các tháng thức lớn,
nhiều tăng trường kinh tế chí chế, dần số ra hoa tì lệ xinh thấp,
cùng các vấn tế liên chíều và thêm mặt của tế,
hình ăn nền được tăng cường tại vì bỏ phía trên tròn quốc,
tết quả sự kiến đất công buồn ngày trong ngày 1,5 hà sấu,
tên tổng thống hà quốc sẽ tuyên thể nhận trước và bắt đầu công việc ngày lập thức,
mà không có dài đoạn xe rao,
bơi cực tổng thống dùn đã bị tế sách của hình thẳng từ vật qua.